it can't be overstated how rare it is to
see this
aircraft so close together and in
formation
eight three six one thousand one hundred
three one zero one nine standard Double
Tree
takes a extraordinary Folk
feed of 500 miles per hour in what is a
very impressive and carefully
choreographed formation there are
aircraft in front of us there are
aircraft behind us
on the 6th of May they'll be joined by
some 60 other aircraft from across the
Armed Forces
the last time we saw an aerial
procession like it was for the late
Queen's Platinum Jubilee Jim LED that
fly past he's now all too aware of the
unique opportunity this time we are used
to pressure yes maybe slightly different
pressures on Ops Etc but I'd like to
think we've been conditioned uh to uh to
deliver and we're excited to do so
and this is the all a six minute fly
past above their new commander-in-chief
and newly crowned King who'll watch with
members of the royal family from the
balcony of Buckingham Palace and tens of
thousands of people who are expected to
flood them out a site 93 year old
Squadron leader Terence remembers so
clearly from Coronation Day 1953 it's
heated exactly that it was exhilarating
but not as exhilarating as when we
finally landed and
um because we've got our overalls off
and someone shouted bars open and that
we were gone
this was the one and only rehearsal for
all those involved in just under two
weeks time it'll be for real and they
too are likely to never forget it Ashna
horanag Sky News at Raf Bryson